what's going on everyone it is alex from
rosa here from gym launch allen prestige
labs you get 110 million
in revenue and have absolutely nothing
to sell you so if right now you're in a
vehicle
uh or a business and it's not growing
the way you want to grow you're looking
at other people who are doing the same
thing as you and you want to do better
or better than them or as good as them
then i would like to share
uh kind of the nuggets from a
conversation i had yesterday with an
agency owner
um who was kind of struggling with the
same thing so they they're they're an
agency owner
they're in the real estate space and
you've been doing this for a year and a
half
ish and he's like at what point do i
throw in the talent switch industries
right
and this was an awesome conversation
because
um the honest truth is
you're not that good that's why you're
not making money
like just like let that sit for a quick
second like
the reason you're not making money is
because you're not that good
and that's okay because it wouldn't be
reasonable for you to be good
because you just started right and
started is in the business like you're
not 30 years in the business you've been
there for a year
right and so like is it reasonable to
believe that you're gonna have a top one
percent income only having been
in a game where other people have been
doing it for 20 20 years we're in the
top one percent
probably not right and so the question
is then how do you
how do you skip through that so the
first is asking do i think that the
vehicle that i am in is viable
and so the easiest way to do that is
look around and see if there are other
people in the industry that are doing
what you're doing
and if they are succeeding that means
that it is possible and therefore it is
possible for you
so the next piece is understanding
the depth of the value uh and the skills
that are required to be successful and
so let me give you a quick example of
this
i'll give you a theoretical example then
i'll drive it home with the the the real
estate thing
so for those of us in the you know the
u.s
we have one word for snow it's snow
right
um eskimos uh this is from what i heard
they
anybody any of you guys are eskimos you
can let me know if this is true or false
but from what i understand they have
seven different words for snow
all right it's because the different
types of snow and
you could reason that eskimos understand
snow
better than we do because it's literally
all they have
and so the nuance that they have
for what snow is is more delineated
right and so when i was talking to this
um
real estate agent agency uh i was like
so why are your clients not staying on
the obvious answer is they're not making
money but he's like but he's like some
clients we kill it with some clients we
don't kill it for he's like i got one
guy who's doing 250 000
a month um just using the leads that we
send him and i was like right
that's because of him and not you
think about it i was like all right so
what is that person doing that's
different than the rest of your clients
right he's like from what i understand i
mean he's just it's just he's just
calling him up
and i was like that would be the same
thing as looking at what i do all day
and just saying yeah i mean alex just
makes money just hops on meetings
there's a little bit more to it than
that right it's the depth of the
understanding it's looking at the sky
and saying oh it's white it's snowing
right when in reality an expert says oh
there's seven different types of snow
and this is subtype a
right if if you were to ask me how do i
make you know like there's only free
offers and non-free offers i'd be like
no there's
19 types of ways to monetize the word
free
like oh alex might know more about that
right it's because i have more volume
the guys who are the eskimos see snow
every day and so
they've been doing it their whole lives
and of course they have more delineation
for what types of snow
there are and so the solution for this
particular owner was
this is what i would recommend to him he
may or may not do this
but it will be the thing that will make
him successful is i was like
fly out to the guys doing 250 000 a
month off of your leads and soak up
everything how many times does he call
in what intervals what's the first thing
he says on the phone what's the
intonation
how does he follow up right after the
phone call
where where does he meet them how soon
does he meet them is the meeting in
person is it a zoom call or is it
is it you know is it a phone call is he
setting up for someone else
when they do show up what's the contract
look like what does that conversation
look like how does he walk around
the room when he positions himself and
presents the contract when he orders the
houses for the showing
how does he order them does he order the
most expensive one first then something
else second and then the one he wants to
sell them
like what's the process looking and then
after the person says yes how does he
close the deal out and make sure that
he's getting paid
he's like well i don't know any of that
stuff it was like right and that's why
you're not making money i was like if
you were the top
absolutely if you knew more about how to
make real estate agents money
we wouldn't be having this conversation
because you'd be making them money
right and so everyone's unwilling to do
the thing which is to
to plant the roots right you got to
plant the roots deep
and the only way to have that level of
certainty because if someone says that
to him
these leads are crap right for example
he could look back at them and say no
they're not you're doing it wrong
because he has the certainty and the
conviction that he has done it
and he knows that and that there's only
two ways to have that level of
conviction you can either be a sociopath
and lie
or you can have done it there is no
other trick right
like i could speak with confidence in
saying that i know that gym launch is
better at serving gyms because we have
more seven-figure gyms than most people
that have in their entire freaking
franchises
right i have 1500 success stories
i know our stuff works right and so i
can have that conviction like there's
just
there's no question about it i did 33
turnarounds for two years
right two years i spend in my hotel
rooms
everyone forgets about that stuff like
how do we learn how to sell supplements
so well
because i i would stand in front of a
room of complete strangers
and day after day after day i would
close these rooms
full of people to buy supplements right
and the first
six months i did it i didn't close
anyone because i couldn't figure out how
to sell them and then i stumbled into
one success
and then another success another success
and then it became a system and it
became so repeatable i could do it in my
sleep
right but we were like well what's the
hack right now you can learn from
somebody who's already learned that
that's how you
fast track success i was on the same
call and there was um
a lady on there who who said um i might
have
been her but it was the point is
if you can't learn from other people's
failures
then it means that you are literally
going to have to make every single
mistake yourself which is possibly the
stupidest thing you can do
like you obviously should learn from
your own mistakes but wise people learn
from other people's mistakes and even
better they learn from other people's
successes
right i someone yesterday who was on
that same call say like well i don't
know if that like
what you're saying is is right for xyz
i'm like who do you think has more
perspective about snow this is your
first winter
i've been living in alaska for the last
20 years
like i was like if you absolutely want
to go make the mistake you can
absolutely go make it i was like but
it's stupid as [ __ ]
right think about it and so
to wrap this up in terms of like if you
were not seeing the success that you
believe that you were quote owed which
you're not owed anything
right then you have to you you are you
are you earn the success
and you get it through doing and it like
i was talking to another guy yesterday
who's an entrepreneur they're doing a
few million bucks a month
right and it was funny because hearing
his story is the same
story it's the same story that every
successful entrepreneur has
the same story so listen to it and if
it's not your story
then it's why you're not where you want
to be
every single successful entrepreneur has
a rocky cut scene
they have a two-year four-year six-year
period of time
where no one talks about it and they did
the same thing over and over
and over and over again and then finally
they have mastery and then at that point
they transfer that skill to a new
opportunity a new vehicle
and then they blow up overnight that's
how it happens
all right the guy that i was speaking
with yesterday has an amazing selling
system he's very good at building sales
teams that are both outbound and inbound
right great guy how did he learn how to
do it
he saw all these leads that were
happening online all these opt-ins that
no one was calling
for for digital products and he's like
and he was a good sales person at that
point he said i'll bet you i can figure
out a way
to get these people to buy and what did
he do he started picking up the phone
and every day he would do hundreds of
dials hundreds of dials to these lists
that were just
plowing through that no one was talking
to and then he finally figured out how
to get him to say yes to the first phone
call and then he figured out how to set
them for the second call and then he
figured out how to make the offer
on the next call and close him right but
it took
a all the time of learning how to sell
which took him years
and then he applied it to a new vehicle
and then did more reps with his initial
skill
and then he learned a system and then
once he applied that system he was able
to show other people et cetera right
he blew up for me i did 4 000 sales
consultations
4 000 000
thousand all right sales consults in
person
it's a lot and so so it's like when we
talk about sales stuff
the nuances are evident the difference
between somebody who just talks about
sales that you've seen in a video
right and somebody that you can that
someone's who's providing excessive
value
is because of the nuance that you only
learn through repetition
right from actually putting time under
the bar which is the word that i use
from the fitness
space like you have to put your time
under the bar there is no shortcut i was
on a podcast
where they were asking me they're like
it seems like you've you've you know
you've had this this great success
really quickly quick is relative right
but
um he was like and if if the people who
are listening want to shortcut that
success what do they do and i was like
you're not
that's the answer you're not going to
because the
the skill is the base of the pyramids
the foundation
right if your foundation's this small
because you only spent six months doing
a rocky cut scene
then the peak of that pyramid is small
but you give me a base that's like this
and it's hundreds of feet deep you can
build a skyscraper taller than anything
you've ever seen
right but the foundation is the piece
that no one can take from you no one can
take my experiences from it
right and the skills that were shaped
from that and so
right now if you're not seeing what you
want to see it's because you haven't put
the time in you have put the time into
the bar you haven't gotten the reps in
you haven't done the volume
right and so if you see someone that is
doing something better than you
then go and observe and then execute
right iterate sorry um replicate before
you iterate
go do it and then until you can do it as
well as them
don't change anything once you can do it
as well as them
or better than them then you've earned
the right
to iterate on someone else's system that
is my advice
so this was a passionate one for you um
it was just because it stemmed from
so many conversations have culminated
this if you want to figure out
how to how a chiropractor is doing well
go to chiropractors are doing well and
offer to work for free
all right now you're not going to work
for free for me i get a dm i get two
dm's a day like hey man
i'll work for free if i can just spend
time with you no you have no value to
provide to me
don't ask right but
there are other people who are who are
probably closer you know i mean like
go message bill gates and say hey bill
uh you know i'll work really hard
and i'll i'll stand next to you he's not
gonna accept that like no person who's
who's like really really making money is
ever
like because you're just going to
literally take from them you have no
value to provide
right instead have value can provide
which might be like working the front
desk it might be cleaning the facility
might be doing anything so that you can
be around a business owner
and then you can learn skills that you
can then apply all right
like when i when we did the gym
turnarounds i worked the front desk for
33 different gyms
it's a lot of gyms right and so i got a
feeling for how
how the floor is laid out how the
lobbies need to be laid out how you can
maximize your sales how you can have
more guys selling in the same space
right all those things happen because of
time under the bar so i'm spending 20
years in alaska looking at snowfall
after snow
after snowfall and saying ah that's the
detail oh when you pick up the phone say
it like this
right because i tried it that way it
didn't work right and if you have to go
ram your head on the wall and not learn
from other people's mistakes that's dumb
so yes moral of the story is
put the time in you will you will
achieve your success faster by taking
the year or two of rocky cutscene and
then blowing up
look at how everyone else's successes
they didn't blow up
like they didn't they didn't just blow
up right
there's there's the rocky cutscene
period if you haven't had that period
you probably won't blow up so just start
putting the time in now
to get your rocky cut scene done to have
the skill that you can then apply to the
new opportunity
that arises the sales guys opportunities
you figured out outbound calls where
there's a huge gold mine
right for me i figured out there
apparently there's a lot of gyms who
wanted to learn how to get customers
right
profitably i didn't know i figured
everyone was opening their full capacity
i didn't know
right and then it turns out a lot of
people wanted to have that right um
billy gene who i talk about all the time
he did cold calling for three years or
two years before he ever started
marketing
right that was the rocky cut scene
periods where he sharpened his sword
that's where he learned how to sell
right and so all of these things right
look at your
path look at the rocky cut scene that
you have or haven't done
and just get it done and then after that
you'll build the base of the pyramid so
you can have the peak that you want
rather than consistently building off of
a peak a foundation that's this big
and never being able to pass five or ten
thousand dollars a month right
because you haven't earned it right and
the marketplace knows that they can
delineate between who really has trench
knowledge
and who is pretending and that's pretty
much it
so that's all i got for you happy
wednesday keep being awesome catch you
soon
bye